Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2 story
picks up three years after the events of
2019's reboot in Modern Warfare Captain
Price's iconic Task Force 141 is now
fully assembled and of course another
threat of global terrorism has emerged
fresh new mechanics more flexibility in
how you complete missions and a host of
callbacks to the original series make
Modern Warfare 2's campaign feel
satisfying despite an increase in
difficulty both teams meet in the middle
this rebooted version of Task Force 141
features price and the familiar faces of
Simon ghost Riley Kyle Gaz Garrick and
John SOB McTavish however Modern Warfare
2 introduces a new ally with Colonel
Alejandro Vargas of the Mexican Special
Forces
station Chief lasts were I thought we
were on a first name basis this must be
serious while this is a different story
than 2009's Modern Warfare 2. it does
reintroduce General Shepard from the
original campaign Modern Warfare 2019's
Kate Laswell and the PMC group known as
Shadow company all make a return as well
playing as members of Task Force 141 you
are put to the test when a United States
airstrike kills alcatala leader General
gorbani whose successor Hassan ziani
vows revenge and teams up with an
international drug cartel to transport
U.S ballistic missiles Hassan plans to
launch the missiles against United
States targets and it falls upon Task
Force 141 to stop this from happening
the campaign is a globetrotting affair
sending you to fight in places like
Amsterdam Mexico Chicago and even parts
of al-mazra the fictional setting of war
zone 2.0's map this gives a refreshing
variety to the scenery from mission to
Mission Modern Warfare 2 offers a bit
more personality to the characters you
play and fight alongside than in past
games as there are now dialogue options
to speak to your fellow soldiers and ask
questions this is totally optional and
you can choose to say nothing but it's
nice to have an extra layer of dialogue
I really enjoy the Chit Chat between
gunfight and it brings more life into
Side characters who could easily fall
flat Vara a character introduced in
Modern Warfare 2019 resurfaces as an
ally in violence and timing but it's a
bit disappointing that she doesn't play
more of a role in the campaign
especially since she was last seen
teamed up with price for modern
warfare's post-launch story in Warzone
she was featured in the fight alongside
price as she slowly helped reassemble
task force one for one which indicated
that she would be a new addition to
prices Force but this doesn't come to
pass sadly however Alejandro feels like
a good addition to Captain Price's
ever-growing team of allies when he's
recreated as task force 141's guide
through Mexico he quickly learn he's a
man willing to risk everything to
protect his fictional city of Los alamas
from the corruption of the cartel thus
being the perfect guy to help get the
stolen missiles out of the cartel's
hands and is easily a character you
start to care about when [ __ ] hits the
fan and I'd welcome his return to the
franchise in future stories without
giving anything away Modern Warfare 2's
quest to locate the missiles and stop
the terrorists is filled with twists and
betrayals just like the original Modern
Warfare 2. Infinity Ward does a solid
job of balancing The Nostalgia of the
original series while also giving a
brand new and engaging narrative Call of
Duty Modern Warfare 2 features 17
campaign missions and these range from
large-scale movie style action set
pieces to dialed back stealth sessions
it's pretty much everything you'd expect
from a Call of Duty campaign there's
really not much added in terms of major
Innovation here to really wow you but
the missions pack a lot of fun and
Nostalgia as the campaign features
several classic Modern Warfare missions
with new twists the game also provides
some missions that feel more openable
than we've seen in the past giving you
more opportunities to explore different
tactics for a fight some stealth
missions let you scour the area for the
perfect sniper point to line up a
collateral kill While others just give
you multiple Pathways to decide how you
want to attack or sneak past your
enemies this Freedom isn't as vast as
playing an open world RPG but the added
exploration and opportunities is a
welcome change the Call of Duty's usual
led by the hand campaign style for
example the mission close air is very
similar to Call of Duty modern warfare's
Death from Above Mission with the
player-controlled AC-130 Gunship
sequence in close air you play as
members of Shadow company who are
providing air support to the AC-130 for
ghost soap and Alejandro this was a fan
favorite mission in Modern Warfare and
close air provides an experience that's
just as satisfying as you destroy whole
buildings with the power of the AC-130
I criticize Modern Warfare 2's Advanced
AI in the multiplayer beta but the
campaign's enemy NPCs proved to be a
much greater adversary unfortunately I
can't say your AI allies are quite as
capable so expect to do most of the work
in taking down enemies
heading into the first deck the vehicle
Chase sequences are a staple of Call of
Duty campaigns and Modern Warfare 2 has
one of my favorites violence and timing
is another instance of Modern Warfare 2
issuing the usual linear feel of
missions in COD games to offer a variety
and player choice the mission hits a few
fun and over the top moments with a
satisfying vehicle chase a brief period
of hanging upside down from an aircraft
while in a gunfight and vehicle hijacked
Shenanigans part of the fun in violence
and timing stems from Modern Warfare 2's
new maneuvering mechanic which gives you
the ability to quickly swap seats in
vehicles and even stand on the roof of
cars to hop over and hijack an enemy's
ride all of these actions let you choose
how do you want to accomplish the
mission you can opt to stay in one
vehicle assuming it doesn't get
demolished during the Skirmish or you
can hop from one hijacked vehicle to
another as you work your way through the
enemy Convoy its level of dynamism that
injects greater throws into a sequence
that is already a high octane
Blockbuster set piece while the game
features mostly the same equipment as
previous years Modern Warfare 2 adds a
new crafting layer to the game some
missions require you to do some light
Scavenging to craft tools and weapons
such as mines smoke bombs shivs and a
pry tool which is used to open locked
crates and doors finding supplies to
craft pry tools does get a bit tedious
after the first few times and I
sometimes wish that could just
Incredible Hulk my way through more
doors nevertheless it was more of a
minor annoyance than something that
ruined the experience and in its current
form it feels like experimentation for
something coming in future Call of Duty
content the campaign is generally the
starting point for a Call of Duty game
where you're introduced to all the tools
and mechanics also found in multiplayer
and additional modes as someone who
plays all the Call of Duty campaigns
starting on regular difficulty and then
completing on veteran I was surprised to
find regular offered more of a challenge
than usual even with this default
setting you can die in just a few
bullets but some of my struggles may
also be due to Advanced AI in Modern
Warfare 2. as in some Style missions I
found the enemy NPC spotted me easily no
matter how stealthily I tried to play
although it felt like AI was more
intuitive in their searches during
stealth missions there were times where
I was confused as to how the enemy
spotted me the eagle-eyed vision might
just be a little too good to the point
where sometimes they felt unfair I died
way more than I ever expected which was
quite a humbling experience the increase
in difficulty also highlighted one of
the campaign's biggest issues which is
its handling of checkpoints these were
spread out pretty far in some missions
and I would have to replay a large chunk
of a mission all over again if I died
while other missions saved my place in
awkward points in the action several
times I died and respawned right near
the enemy who just killed me and it made
for a tough recovery especially in the
stealth missions on PlayStation 5 the
campaign Graphics were sharp and
everything ran smoothly your personal
experience could vary depending on your
platform but I didn't run into any
crashes major bugs or performance issues
the success of Call Of Duty Modern
Warfare 2019 left big shoes for the sea
try and fill but overall Modern Warfare
2 is a strong successor in an early
preview of Modern Warfare 2 I wasn't
impressed with the new maneuverability
mechanics nor did I expect the changes
to make such an impact on the game
however I was pleasantly surprised with
how much I enjoyed the freedom to tackle
scenarios in my own way including all
the carjacking the variety of locations
from mission to Mission also ensured
there was never a dull moment my time
with Modern Warfare 2 and Task Force 141
was a blast and it truly feels like
Infinity Ward created this campaign as
The Greatest Hits list for the series my
surprise enjoyment of the added open
world set pieces and new maneuverability
gives me hope that these elements of
Freedom may become more of a staple for
the franchise and that's a future for
Call of Duty that I can get behind
nice work
we need to find where they're moving
Hassan and the receptive
why do we know we'll talk
I can be very persuasive